what up reject nation look at us we're
back with brooklyn nine-nine and you're
our first mikey experiment well not our
first we actually have like a gazillion
microphones we've got so much and we
just can't see so much sound can't seem
to figure it out
we'll get it
yeah we have though the weirdest my
dream is consistent sound for youtube
channel my dream someday is to take an
entire day just to figure out the sounds
once and for all yeah
you have so many things on the walls
tears like that this is a sound it's all
really good you're our trial for this
one to see how this one goes
unfortunately the best way to run these
tests is to see what it's like when we
do a full recording yeah we're back at
it now that the new place is here this
is episode something another thing 11 so
if you guys leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated let us know if this
sounds all right it's a little much
we're probably just going to switch to
headphones like my brother doesn't have
a little earpiece here it's probably the
most efficient way to do it honestly
because we usually have two to three
people on camera with us that's why it's
a little bit more complicated i'm also
like i don't want this like giant-ass
pole and mike in the thumbnails i really
care about that i'm pretty particular
about the thumbnails anywho it's a lot
of crap i just told you guys subscribe
and click that bell and also um yeah you
can check us on patreon that'd be very
much appreciated thanks to the boys at
prepper for helping us out of these down
let's get to it
[Music]
are you eating an italian sub for
breakfast i am but amy said i should eat
more veggies so i got extra
pepperoncinis smort
love a good pepperoni oh no
you need to watch yourself i'm sorry
cop
all right
are you going to arrest me for dancing
you call that dancing
is dancing
oh please what is happening let's do
this
dancing over situation diffused
all right you guys are adorable tell me
everything the doctor says about your
uterine climate
and also that gross big news is this
something other people would keep
private big time we're trying to have a
baby oh
wow that is awesome that's big news
charles i thought you were sterile i
distinctly remember you using the phrase
shooting dust yes oh
yes i imagined that
[Applause]
yeah i still don't know why you dove in
crotch first
first
stephen we're gonna fill out form 38e
dash j1 stating non-compliance we send
it to the da but do they process it
right away no because they're
overwhelmed
[Laughter]
so your court date won't be set for six
or eight weeks and even then you're
gonna have to block out the whole day
because they don't give you a specific
time
no no
it's a window
[Laughter]
i thought we were gonna try to scare him
there's nothing scarier than the
realities of the municipal court system
now come on let's get back in there and
tell them about how bad the website is
look
i'll talk
about the turnout i was hoping for maybe
i should've offered free strudel then at
least scully would've come there's free
strudel
i'm gonna come at you and you're gonna
take me down
you better impress me if you want that
recommendation to be good i'm gonna try
sarge
here we go
[Music]
me a wowie
and that's what you get for lying about
free strudel karma's a [ __ ]
oh god
who's catherine
your ex-wife is here that one more
oh
there's no male thing but it's my sperm
how did you even find out i wanted it
because it counts under my name storage
facility called me saying that you were
looking to make a withdrawal so i went
ahead and withdrew it for you i have all
of your sperm oh my god oh hey charles
i'll never have a baby with you because
i don't love you and a child's not gonna
fix that oof when we started doing the
silly voice i thought it was gonna be
more fun
i hit some dumb ass with my car now he's
suing me what i want is for you to use
your badge and your gun to intimidate
him into dropping the case i'm gonna
take your sperm and i'm gonna dump it
into the east river please don't do that
there will never be the possibility
of a little pie-faced charles boyle jr
proud of it it's me what a terrible
person the sperm is her legal possession
it also says that she and i quote owns
your dignity you initialed right next to
that
total disaster i'll never be happy in my
life
why are you smiling because this is
exactly what we've trained for it's a
hostage situation and we're gonna bring
your boys home
here's what we know about eleanor oh my
good wedding day i should have known it
was a mistake when she said i suppose
instead of i do
all right
hey sergeant how are you
well my baby cries at the side of my
face now
if it helps i brought you some soothing
ginger tea don't repair the place where
my nose came off my skull i don't know
but it's supposed to have healing vapors
so try inhaling it thank you
oh no no no no
oh
no
wow
do you threaten that nine-year-old man
for me yet but the guy you hit was 90.
yeah and you would know that if you had
talked to him which obviously you did
not so goodbye
we need proof of life i'd be happy to
dump one of the containers out of the
window no no don't do that please don't
dump my sperm on us hello ma'am
[Laughter]
gina take a statement yes thank you i'm
gonna get this guy to admit to crimes he
hasn't even committed no that would be a
huge problem
[Laughter]
the guy wanted to talk to a real person
not a cop that's why he asked for me
actually i asked for you because we went
to high school together what stephen
henderson we had a bunch of classes
together no
no
eleanor
jake
charles okay you just said your own name
this is the only one
okay so
as soon as she comes back in here i'm
gonna grab that cup right out of her
hands and run like hell you think
that'll work i don't just think it will
i know it might
[Laughter]
there are two real containers one is in
a safe location and this
is the other one
or rather
it was the other one
no
what are you doing i'm sorry but i don't
have a choice jake i'm gonna go bully an
old priest so i can get my sperms back
priest
friend
no no carl what are you doing no no no
no no not the keys no oh i should have
known you're a hugger not a shaker
rejected
i've never been rejected from anything
me neither did you say rejected or
ejected i've been rejected a lot my
application was so good you know what
i've also been ejected
how could you excuse me it's the only
explanation you're mad that i broke your
face and i burned your whole body well
grow up
i have a roth i.r.a
i eat wheat toast you grow up
here's the letter that i sent amy
santiago is one of the finest detectives
in my precinct nay the entire nypd yeah
i even used the word nay
you would question my integrity is solid
oh oh no oh no i gotta sneeze no no no
there's gonna be lots of blood
here quick hand me those keys what will
you give me for them
a dollar for soda mine are all wet yes
obviously i'll give you that
soda only cost 75 cents you fool see you
later sucka
didn't even give him
[Laughter]
[Music]
stay straight you interrupted the song
for that
yeah yep
she came up onto the sidewalk and
fractured my hip
you were a pedestrian are you totally a
pedestrian
if you're sitting on a bench
yawns are coming
hi there i'm jake this is my best friend
charles he's trying to have a baby you
get it come here you
charles i know you're mad but you have
to talk to me funny how getting taste in
the back can break your heart
i really wanted to be a papa and you
ruined it you pop blocked me i know
i have a biological father and he's a
nightmare he never played catch with me
he never taught me how to ride a bike i
had to learn how to shave from watching
home alone makes sense it's like die
hard for kids
oh my god it is but i do know that
you're gonna be a great dad with or
without your boy oil no not gonna say it
but you will adopt my guy adopt i sent
the recommendation letter to the wrong
place i thought you were applying to be
a mentor not a mentee you thought i
wanted to be a sam not a sam are you
insane well you should be a sam no i
should be a sam
you are ready to be teaching others
i made a call you're going to be a
mentor oh my god i'm so sorry for ever
questioning your integrity thank you no
no no don't stand back look i'm still
very scared of you
i got stephen to talk yeah it's
fantastic how did you do it did you
finally show him the municipal court
website
[Laughter]
i found something we bonded over she
didn't even know who i was and we were
good friends on more than one occasion
she's called me gina that's her own
i'm in love and i'm going to be a dad
and there's nothing you could do to stop
me so goodbye forever oh and one more
thing tell hercules i'll see you about
spin class on sunday now goodbye yeah we
were looking at possible donors on the
way over yeah yeah yeah
check out this guy i like him he went to
yale oh wait that says yeel university
swipe him off this is fun
that's weird that guy kind of looks like
my dad wait a minute oh my god no you
cannot use his sperm my son would be
your brother
[Laughter]
oh
it was eleanor all along
[Music]
good shiz
how long were you waiting for that one
john where sorry
[Music]
how long were you waiting for that one
i
was anticipating the right opportunity
but it never arose within the plot of
the episode
there was no big reveal involving
eleanor so i still thought it was fun he
was pretty funny thank you that's funny
you did a funny joke thanks man funny is
good that's uh welcome to asmr standard
comedy asmr what's the deal with this
[Music]
let me get my hot breath in there some
some good mouth clicks all right guys
this is the episode where you whip out
podcast mike's for
this is the one this is brooklyn nine
now this is the one where we're gonna
we're gonna talk forever
warren's
warren's microphones up close to your
face most pro sounding brooklyn
nine-nine discussion
impossible
that was really fun you know i've
thought about adopting i've always
wanted to adopt instead you know like
even though they don't end on adopting i
like that message at the end that a dad
comes in all form shapes and sizes
and it doesn't have to be just you know
from your own sperm dna itself i feel
there's a different association to be
had with it
however i do
think that a lot of times you know like
my people have shitty dads and they find
a father figure instead and that could
be the one you called that i have a i
mean
i don't want him to be the one to i
don't want to just put his personal life
out there but i do know someone whose
dad abandoned them and then he has a
someone who their
the mother his mother started dating
like the boyfriend and been the
boyfriend for many many many years and
he calls him dad instead and uh
yeah so i i do like the way this this
all ended ultimately yeah like katherine
hahn also
just played villain and wasn't like
funny villain she was
legit like a frustrating [ __ ] yeah she
wasn't funny yeah no totally she felt
very real and i thought catherine oh
he's gonna be like a funny quirky
villain and no no you seem like a pretty
pretty glass she knew that to make the
joke funnier it was for her to not play
it funny and then to let the other
things like the
the uh reveals about the whole uh the
how it just kept escalating with the
person she hit how it just kept getting
compoundingly worse and the more it got
closer to actually seeing the guy
uh it was funnier just because of how
straightforward she was in the beginning
about the whole situation so i think
that uh
some some solid solid comedy right there
so some good physical comment there's a
lot of physical comedy this episode
mm-hmm
a lot a lot john why don't you talk
about the physical comedy
yeah john yeah through the the bald
either i'll find different ways to let
you know i'm segueing you gotcha instead
of being like hey look look at me
the baton here
no i thought there's a lot of really fun
physical comedy especially obviously
with amy and terry
and uh your audio sounds so much better
than mine why is that i'm not sure
this is crazy it's [ __ ] john's
favoriting himself no that sounds better
now
yeah it's just about the angle and the
proximity to your mouth
god damn it it's okay
it's working progress
uh yeah
yeah i enjoyed the uh the terry and uh
uh
amy storyline of uh you know yeah him
being increasingly afraid of her and him
inc
undergoing increasing levels of pain and
anguish and justice league the way that
she uh
that paid off
and two yeah all the physical like sight
gags and stuff about like this this this
priest scenario speaking of psychics you
guys clearly know what this looked like
uh make yours make your pervy jokes
people i was gonna say why wha what do
you mean oh
oh like a big uh lolly like a big
popsicle
yeah mm-hmm
because big black pops it's almost
summer time yeah get your charcoal
popsicle going i didn't know terry crews
was in this video
hey
that's right he is in in more ways than
than one
because there's two
anyway there's a lot of good physical
comedy
in this episode and a lot i don't know i
thought all the plot lines had uh
had like obviously like the charles and
and uh and jake is the center piece and
is the most engaging but i loved
watching yes terry become more and more
frightened of amy and then
holt doing his dancing and then later on
the whole bit with the interrogation and
gina talking to this guy and then
finally that being this catapult for
rosa to identify with how much they both
get aggravated by her yeah uh yeah
they're really fun a lot of really fun
games
and a lot of really fun even just like
with the physical timing of things like
scully showing up out of nowhere when
terry mentions strudel just like little
little things like that we're just like
so perfectly timed or uh even the bit
with skully and the uh hitchcock in the
garage and the dollar and the soda
yeah there's like so many great little
back and forth quippy bits and things
very true yeah and uh
i liked what everybody had to learn this
time but i'm glad i'm so i'm sad and i'm
glad i'm sad we didn't get to see the
municipal court website and just how
nightmarish those pull down menus are
because it always mystifies me how we
live in a time and place especially in
the greatest country on earth these
united states of america like all the
greatest yeah yeah but yet all the like
state and government
technology sucks it's like these
websites don't work
and like you know even like basic things
like wi-fi when you got to go to a place
like that it's like just slow and it
doesn't work and you're like
why why do we keep getting told we're in
the most state-of-the-art place in the
world and we can't get any of this [ __ ]
right
you know
because it's not it's not gonna i'm not
gonna go off on a on a rant about
capitalism now hey
capitalism is good
oh
sure depending on how you use it sure
maybe it's what's built this country it
is
it is no there's a lot of corruption in
capitalism if you use capitalism
properly it could be good
for a time
what are you talking about
what are you thinking about i'm thinking
of like bare minimum capitalism minim
mid-stage early stage capitalism perhaps
yeah like starting up a youtube channel
and deciding to make your living off of
it is a form of capitalism sure yeah
that's not bad
no a lot of people who do it if you're
watching this you're supporting everyone
whoever does it no it's not that but
it's it's it's a part of a larger
ecosystem of of interconnected things
that all are subject to the tenets of
capitalism those of which are
debatable
yeah
it's what it's about what capitalism
does to our human instincts
more so than this i think the the greedy
part of capitalism is the bad part
and it incentivizes that greed though
yeah depending on how you
i think i think there's plenty of people
who
there's like other
people in uh where are we going on the
stage i have no idea
not the time nor the place to debate
i've got him
i didn't mean to seriously bring up the
topic of capitalism i was more joking oh
no no capitalism in many ways has
destroyed our our country in in more
ways than one but the
planet
yeah absolutely uh but the
concept of it you know like from the
small business owner days of america i
think are like the great times of
capitalism that have now ventured off
into like
corporate
shenanigans that have destroyed our
world and our society yeah but you know
like
i'm a fan of like the old ideals of like
yeah you know start your own business
and and
be a small business owner or something
like that like those kind of things you
know
start a business employ a few people
make something good you can give to the
world be self-employed yeah like there's
definitely uh things about or learning
to
you know make investments in profit but
then i think there's a lot of the
corruption there's
it's very obvious we really need to dive
into
how it's been for the past few decades
alone of how there's been a lot of just
complete total corporations are people
greg
you know
there's there's got to be better ways to
to go about it you know there aren't
we won't see them in our lifetimes no
it's not american
no and then you know if you
yeah anyway
all right
this is this is fun
it's a weird episode review
a lot of great plots though i like this
episode a lot i can props like you said
to katherine han because i feel like
i've been seeing her for so many years
and she especially is really good at
showing up
playing the character being 100
committed and giving
just what it needs without ever feeling
like she's trying to steal focus and i
always appreciate that about catherine
han which is why i'm so happy that in a
post-wan division world she is really
getting her flowers in recognition
because i think she deserves that [ __ ]
totally
totally yeah man
all right guys well hey
i think it's time to do a page
pandemic jones page i haven't checked
the list but i'm assuming you're still
on there i think he's on there pj was
thinking about who would i want to um
be the father of my child
and it's definitely you it's definitely
yeah i think pandemic jones would make a
hell of a dad
because he'd make it all about
me
[Music]
he'd find a way to give his sperm our
way and then being a pandemic jones i
could finally fulfill my master plan
with that pj sperm
where my seed would his seed would
spread under my name
throughout throughout the world get a
child of greg alba
it's pj sperm but under mine spreading
under my name then then
everyone would because it's like you
would read the list of all the great
qualifications that pj has but he'd use
my name and be like but this is all
technically you know under that because
it's capitalism so
i would buy pj's by the right i buy the
right said pattern is first i'd buy the
rest played them worldwide and then i
would exploit it worldwide so that way
uh in every state where people have a
child they would always go wow this list
is great of this person and then before
you know it there'd be a little greg
and but he's looking like pj though but
through
legality titling it would be greg
everywhere across the world uh so pj i'm
talking about
your sperm my own house
yeah how do you feel about that this
only makes sense if you watch the
episode and if you ever threaten to
leave the patreon we're going to dump
all of your reserve sperms and then what
will you do
i'd swim in it
and then i'd be people come out of spare
men i just thought of several new pj
acronyms
all right we'll see you guys soon
[Music]